hey guys I'm Dave and it's time for a
game spot news update it's time to put
on your robe and wizard hat and get
ready to head back to Azeroth as World
of Warcraft Legion has a release date
the release date for blizzards upcoming
world of warcraft expansion Legion has
been leaked online just a day before
blizzcon kicks off the date was spotted
online in an image hosted on the
battlenet website which reads expected
game release on over 4 sep tember 21st
2016 the image also details some
pre-purchase bonuses including a level
100 character boost and early access to
the new demon hunter hero class a
standard edition of the game will be
priced at forty-nine dollars 99 cents
and on top of that the digital deluxe
edition will include an in-game mount
pet and digital content for both diablo
3 and starcraft 2 the $69 world of
warcraft legion was first announced at
Gamescom in august this year the
expansion will raise the level cap to
110 and introduce a new class called the
demon hunter Legion will add a host of
new content including a new continent
titled the broken Isles as well as new
customizable artifacts weapons and new
dungeons and raids expansion is also set
to revamp the player versus player
progression system the beta for World of
Warcraft Legion starts is here and
players can sign ups participate on the
battlenet website so are you excited by
the expansion if you're a recovering wow
addicts will Legion be enough you to
rejoin the Horde let us know in the
comments below until next time I've been
Dave and you can find me on Twitter at
irregular Dave and for all your world of
warcraft Legion news stay tuned in to
gamespot com